mais
alain delon dans quelques instants romy
schneider va atterrir sur l'aéroport de
nice côte d'azur
m un petit peu ému je me cache la balle
je suis un peu ému parce que finalement
c'est à peu près ce jour pour jour après
dix ans se sont écoulés depuis la
première fois où je suis venu
l'accueillir sur un aéroport 1958 en
effet vous n'était pas encore une
vedette à cette époque là non elle était
une énorme vedette européenne moi pas du
tout j'ai débuté dans leur baraque
derrière elle va être votre partenaire
dans un film
oui va être mon partenaire dans le film
que nous allons commencer la semaine
prochaine à saint tropez qui s'intitule
la piscine
quel rôle at-elle joué d'abord il faut
dire une chose c'est que c'est un rôle
de femme robyn maintenant est une femme
ce n'est plus une jeune fille pour bien
se mettre à l'évidence ça n'est plus ici
je n'ai plus à régler julien ronde c'est
vraiment une femme d'ailleurs vous allez
vous apercevoir tout à l'heure
j'ai déjà fait deux
v
romy schneider avec beaucoup de joie que
nous vous retrouvons sur la côte d'azur
romy schneider voudrait tourner un film
à saint tropez ses retrouvailles avec l
un des leurs un petit peu d'émotion dans
la voix peut-être oui heureuse de
retrouver très près alain delon alain
delon tout à l'heure vous m'avez dit que
vous étiez ému vous aussi en rencontrant
c'est normal oui bien sûr si vous êtes
vous même eu entre temps le métro il ya
longtemps que vous êtes durs montés sur
une scène de théâtre et arts ina depuis
paris depuis la dernière fois que vous
avez joué avec alain depuis la dernière
fois avec alain et depuis la tournée la
mouette le kilowatt
ça fait combien de temps qu'on n'avait
plus revu à la non non c'est l'éternel
et la dernière fois que vous aviez joué
avec alain méar ce don